[موسيقى]
راى احد الملوك ان اسنانه تكسرت فجيئ له
بمفسر للاحلام اول له الرؤيا بان جميع
اهله سوف يموتون امامه غضب الملك وامر
بنفي المفسر وطلب اخر كان اكثر حكمه
ونباها من الاول فسر له منامه بنفسه معنى
تفسير سلفه لكن في سياق مختلف قال له ابشر
جلاله الملك تقول رؤياك انك ستكون اطول
اهلك عمره
وستكرم عائلتك مدى الحياه فرح الملك ببشرى
المفسر الجديد وامر بضمه الى الحاشيه
الملكيه الى العناوين
ما علاقه امريكا بتفجير اسطنبول حتى ترفض
تركيا تعازيه
صمت الدهرا رئيسه الحكومه تونس تحيي رئيس
اسرائيل
تعريه الحمله الدنماركيه على قطر امام
الفيفا وللقصه بقيه
ول وهران بالجزائر يعيد تمثيل فيلم رامبو
على بائع البيض
فوزي عضوين للكونجرس من بين الابواب
وموسكو تسخر
الامام البخاري اسمه ارفع وسام في
اوزباكستان يمنح للملوك والرؤساء
[موسيقى]
هنا
الورود تكريما لارواح ضحايا الهجوم
الارهابي ويؤكد وزير الداخليه سليمان سولو
القبض على المراه التي وضعت القنبله التي
تسببت في التفجير والتي اعترفت لقوات
الامن التركيه بتلقيها تدريبات على يد
تنظيم بكال ارهابي شماليه سوريا وانها
دخلت الاراضي التركيه بطريقه غير قانونيه
وكانت تعتزم مغادرتها بعد العمليه
الارهابيه نحو اليونان مرحبا
باسطنبول دون ان يقصد منطقه تكسين التي
سميت كذلك لانها كانت مركز تجميع خطوط
المياه ثم تقسيمها الى مناطق المدينه
نصب الجمهوريه الشهير يتوسط ميدان تقسيم
وابرز وتفرعاته شارعه الاستقلال الذي
يزوره يوميا ما يقاربه ثلاثه ملايين شخص
في هذا الشارع الاستقلال
المتفرع من ميدان الجمهوريه هناك من
يتربصوا باستقلال الجمهوريه فوقف بحسب
وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان سولو وراى
تفجير كانت احدى ادواته السوريه المدربه
عند حزب العمال الكردستاني احلام البشير
لكن احلام العشير عشير الناتو ستتبدد يؤكد
صيله فالرساله وصلت ونحن لا نقبل تعزيه
السفاره الامريكيه فمن يدعم المنظمات
الارهابيه شمال سوريا هو من نفذ الهجوم
ضدنا يقول الرساله وصلت وسنرد برساله قويه
جدا على هذه الرساله نحن لا نقبل تعازي
السفاره الامريكيه ونرفضها لم نشهد مثل
هذا الحادث الارهابي في اسطنبول منذ سته
سنوات
في تحالفهم ودعمهم الارهاب والارهابيين
اما باحتضانهم او تمويلهم او دعمهم في
مناطق سيطراتهم
فيها وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان واشنطن
بالعبث بامن تركيا فقد سبق له ان يتهامها
بتدبير محاوله الانقلاب الفاشله على
النظام التركي قبل سته سنوات توتر
العلاقات بين تركيا وامريكا لم يفجره
تفجير اسطنبول الاخير فهناك ثلاثه ملفات
تسبب هذه العلاقات اولا الدعم الامريكي
لتنظيمات الكرديه المعاديه لتركيا ثانيا
عدم تسليم واشنطن انقره فتح الله جولن
المصنف الارهابيا لدى حكومه بلاده والمتهم
باداره محاوله الانقلاب ثالثا شراء تركيا
منظومه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اس 4 بعد رفض
امريكا بيع تركيا نظام الدفاع الجوي
باتريو
بكل الاحوال ربما تكشف الايام القادمه
ترجمه الحكومه التركيه توعدها من تصفهم
بالارهابيين بالم مضاعف اضعافا في القريب
العاجل في المستقبل القريب سنرد عليهم
وسيشعر اولئك الذين تسببوا بهذا الالم في
شارع الاستقلال بالالم اضعافا مضاعفه فلقد
القينا القبض ايضا على الشخص الذي امره
التنظيم بقدم منافذه التفجير ولو لم نقبض
على الارهابيين لكانوا هربوا الى اليونان
[موسيقى]
وجه الفريق عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
سياده الانتقالي في السودان رساله تهنئه
الى بنيامين نتنياهو الذي فاز في
الانتخابات التشريعيه في اسرائيل والذي كل
ثابت تشكيل الحكومه وكتب البرهان اهنئك
بفوزك في الانتخابات ونرحب
بالاستمرار في تعاونينا من اجل تعزيز
العلاقات في كل المجالات لما فيه مصلحه
المواطنين في البلديه اسرائيل
نفسه اولا برغم انظمه الحمايه العاليه
الدقه فان اسلحه التكنات الاسرائيليه
وذخائررها تسرق بشكل متكرر وربما تباعه في
السوق السوداء
عمليات سرقه اسلحه وذخائر من قواعد عسكريه
تابعه للجيش الاسرائيلي في جنوب فلسطين
المحتله وشمالها التي كانت اخرها سرقه
الضخمه من قاعده هنعبر في الجولان المحتل
والتي قدرت ب 70,000 طلقه و70 قنبله يدويه
رئيسه الحكومه التونسيه نحتاج الى جوجل في
كل مره لتذكر اسمها لم تمارس اي نشاط بارز
بعد خارج اطار يهز راسها مكممه بالصمت في
حضره الرئيس قيس سعيد موافقه على درره
المنطوق اخيرا فعلت السيد نجلاء شيئا
لافتا للانظار بهزات راس صامطه ايضا لكن
بكثير من الابتسام تحيه للرئيس الاسرائيلي
يتحقق في قمه المناخ فهل يندرج هذا
التواصل في اطار التطبيع الذي كان المرشح
الرئاسي قيس سعيد يخونه فاعله اثناء
حملاته لجمع الاصوات
[موسيقى]
تطبيق ماما هي كلمه التطبيع خاطئه
من يتعامل معك شرد الشعب كامل لمده اكثر
من قرب لا يتعامل معه خائن واجب ان يحاكمه
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى المذيعه الكويتيه
فجر السعيد ترشحت للانتخابات النيابيه
وسقطت بل واقفلت قناتها التلفزيونيه فماذا
تفعل تبقى هكذا بدون شغل حاش وكله بل تشجع
على التطبيع مع اسرائيل التي زارتها بحسب
اعترافاتها
سعيد صديق اسرائيل الصهيونيه
حقيقه يعني
دخلت اسرائيل
[موسيقى]
اعطاها الفيفا زبده الحديد الرسائل
السياسيه المحظوره في الملاعب وبالتالي
يرفض الاتحاد الدولي لكره القدم طلب
الدنمارك السماحه للاعبي منتخبنا بارتداء
قمصان تدريب تحمل شعارات حقوقيه في
مونديال قطر حمله الدنمارك على قطر اعادت
الى الواجهه قوانينها للتقسيم العرقي التي
تنتهي فيها حقوق اقليات دينيه وعرقيه في
الاحياء التي يفوق نصف عدد سكانها مواطنون
من اصول غير غربيه حتى وان كان دنماركيه
عند بنك
قبل نحوي اربع سنوات بدات الدانمارك
بالتخطيط لعزل اللاجئين في اسوا مكان يضم
ومحارق نفايات حساسه ومخصص للتجارب الخطره
على الحيوانات خطوه اذنتها مفوضيه الامم
المتحده لحقوق الانسان
يمكن ان يتخيلها احد وهي جزيره صغيره يصعب
الوصول اليها وتضم مركزا بحثيا للامراض
الحيوانيه الخطيره مثل طاعون الخنازير
وداء الكلب وتتوفر فيها المختبرات الخاصه
لهذا الغرض وكذلك اسطبلات الحيوانات
ومحارق النفايات الخطره والملوثه يقول
المثل الدنماركي كثيرون هم الذين يمدحون
ما هو حق ويفعلون ما هو باطل
برنامج للقصه بقيه يكشف باطل حملات
التحريض في الدنمارك على حلم العرب الذي
تحقق بمونديال قطر على هذه الرقات الخضراء
في اسباير الاكاديميه الرياضيه القطريه
وقبل سته اعوام تحديدا في مارس 2016 قدم
الامير فريدريك اندرياس ولي العهد
الدنمارك وعقيلته الاميره ماري الدعم
الكامل لقطر في مشروعيها الرياضي لصحبه
وفد رفيع المستواه من مسؤولين دنماركيه
وطرح نجم كره القدم الدنماركي اي بيسان
مشروعه لتوظيف كره القدم في نشر الوعي
بثقافه طاقه نظيفه والاستلام اذا ما الذي
تغير يا اهل الدنمارك حتى تميل بعد ان كان
بينكم وبين القطريين مالو في هذه السوره
التي استوقفتنا زار الامير
شركات الدنماركيه على تشغيل اكبر حقل
النفطيا في قطر منذ العام
1992 بم باتفاقيه اعلنت قطر عدم تجديدها
في النصف الثاني من عام 2016 معتبر ضربه
قاسمه للشركه التي تساهم باربعه عشر
بالمئه في الناتج الاجمالي المحلي
للدنماركي
خساره الشركه للعقد القطري عرضتها لبيع
اصولها كشركه نفطيه القضيه ليست دفاعا عن
حكومه قطر وهي ليست المدينه الفاضله بكل
الاحوال لكنك تجد نفسك مستهدفا اولا عندما
يمر كاس العالم للفتيات الذي اقيم مؤخرا
في الهند دون اي انتقاد لحكومه
المتهمه بانتهاكاتره لحقوق الانسان
والاقلبيه وثانيا عندما تسمع شهاده
اوروبيه محايده عن طائفيه وعنصريه ضد
المسلمين تحرك بعض المشوشين على مونديال
العرب في قطر
اولئك الذين لا يحبون ان يروا بلدا مسلما
ينظم بطوله كاس العالم
لكن هذا لا ينطبق على جميع المحتاجين هل
يعقل ان تسحب حكومه السويد طفله مسلمه من
حضن عائلتها بحجه الحمايه النفسيه ثم
تضعها في حضن ذكريين مثليين هل هذه هي
الثقافه التي ينازعوننا عليها
ونحب ان يعرفه العالم كما هو رساله الدعاه
بعده لغات في جناح تعريفيا بالاسلام دشنته
وزاره الاوقاف والشؤون الاسلاميه بقطر في
فضائل المونديال
من الفلبين انا عقله من سوريا ونعم
موسى من الفلبين نقدم هذا للناس
وكدعوه خاصه الغير المسلمين
[موسيقى]
جديده استبداله كولومبيا بيكمبوديا حيث
كان مشاركا في قمه دوليه
شوفوا الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد
الذي يتحدث عن الاحتساب الحراري قاصدا
الاحتباس الحراري
من اشد الدول تضررا بالاحتساب الحراري
دعاء جديد يقفز الى تراند الادعيه اطلقه
الرئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السودان
يقول الدعاء الله لا يوفقنا على هذه
الخدمه فردت دموع عراقيه امين الله لا
يوفقكم على هالخدمه
السوداني كان يعرب عن استيائه من خدمات
مستشفيات زال عليها
الشرطه باحد اللصوص لتفكيك عصابه سرقه في
العراق تعيين قاض متهم بالفساد رئيسا
بهيئه النزاهه التي يفترض ان تقضي على
الفساد في البلاد قال لنا مجلس القضاء
الاعلى تعينا كاظم
جمهوري كان قد اعطي سابقا بتهمه الفشل
والفساد والقاضي حيدر حنون جديد انه ليس
سلفستر ستالون في سلسله افلام رامبو انه
والي وهران في الجزائر سعيد سعيود باطلاله
هوليوديه حازمه ينتصر فيها على بائع وجبات
بيض في كشك مخالف اثناء مداهمه مفاجاه هز
قصدك وامشي ترواح اجمع اغراضك واذهب ولا
تمزح معنا
نفس الشيء اليوم قبل همم قبل الرابعه ولا
براكات قدم
وفاء الجماهير لان انا مش شده
وفاهم واصواتهم
اذا كان الموت يقتنعون في بعض الدول
العربيه فانهم يفوزون بالانتخابات في
امريكا
وهذا ما حصل لعضوي الحزب الديمقراطي توني
دي لوكا وبربره اللذين توفي شهر الماضي
رئيس مجلس الدومه الروسي فياتشي سلاب
فولودين سخر مما وصفها بالارواح الميته
التي فازت في الانتخابات النصفيه للكونغرس
الامريكي وقال بولوتين ساخرا ان النظام
السياسيه في الولايات المتحده ميت حرفيا
قبل عضوي الكونجرس
صحيح انا رئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
نانسي بيلوسي لم تقصر يوما في هجاء الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب بعبارات مالوفه الى
حد ما اعتبرته ذات مره انه ليس رجلا بما
يكفي للادلاء بشهادته بشان هجوم الكابيتول
لكنها لم تصفه بالحيوان كما وصفها ترامب
هذا الاسبوع
[موسيقى]
الامام البخاري الذي يسيء بعض القوالين
الى مقامه العلميه والتوثيقي السامي اسمه
يطلق على ارفع وسام في اوزباكستان ويمنح
للملوك والرؤساء الرئيس الازبكي شوكت
ميرضاييف قلد نظيره التركيه رجب طيب
اردوغان وسام الامام البخاري الرفيع
المستوى على هامش اعمال قمه منظمه الدول
التركيه بمدينه سمرقند
شكرا
لا يؤمنون بوجود جهنم في الاخره هل لانهم
عاشوا جهنم في الدنيا كما تندر البعض ام
انهم يسهلون حياه المجرمين كي لا يتوبوا
ابدا ايمن زيدان على خطى سلافه وخارجي
وفايز قزق يمكن وجودا نار ويقال في الشام
يا خبر اليوم بفلوس بكره ببلاش بسالت جنه
ونار انا رايي انه بعد الحياه بعد الموت
في جنه فقط
اذا كان هناك
عالم اخر فهناك جني دائما اثنان باليوم
الاخر ركن اركان الايمان ولا يتم الايمان
الا به ما بعد اليوم الاخر هناك احداث
هناك حساب هناك صراط هناك جنه ونار كل هذه
القضايا ثبتت بادله قطعيه يجب الايمان بها
لان هذا من تمام الايمان بالاخر الممثل
المصري حسين فهمي مصير رن على ان النقاب
يشكل خطرا على المجتمع وليس الدراما
الهابطه التي شكل حسين بنفسه احد اعمده في
بدايته والتي اسهمت على مدى عقود في افساد
حياه اسر كثيره حول عالم العربي انا قلت
ان النقاب خطر على المجتمع انا ما قلتش ان
انا رافض النقاب اللي عايز يلبس نقابلنا
انما
المجتمعنا شوفنا احنا بالضبط كده لان احنا
مرينا في فترات كتيره جدا في مصر النقاب
كان فيها جزء من عمليات ارهابيه تمت في
البلد لان ما حدش شايف مين اللي وراءه
فعشان كده انا في الفتره دي قلت الكلام ده
قلت انك خطر على المجتمع الكمامه الواقيه
من الكرونه وغيرها من الاوبئه ارتكبت
بالاختفاء خلفها الاف الجرائم حول العالم
بحسب صحيفه
ونقلا عن تقارير بوليسيه فلماذا لا يبقى
فهم حسين فهمي الى اعتبار القمامه خطرا
على المجتمع اشترى مسلمون في مدينه دايجوب
بكوريا الجنوبيه قطعه ارض صغيره لبناء
مسجد عليها لكن بعض جيران المسجد عمدوا
الى اجراءات متطرفه لمنع اكمال بنائه شملت
وضع الرؤوس خنازير مقطوعه على طريقه يضع
المتطرفون الخنازير على طرقات المسلمين
لعلمهم بانهم يشمئزون منها علما ان الحمله
على المساجد في كوريا الجنوبيه ليست
الاولى من نوعها نشرت وكاله عيونها
بالكوريه الرسميه للانباء تقريرا تحدثت
فيه عن انتشار ظاهره الاسلام فوبيا في
البلاد مشيره الى نزاع جديد حول بناء دور
العباده الاسلاميه يقدر يتحدى مسلمي كوريا
الجنوبيه ان هناك حوالي 100,000 مسلم
يعيشون في البلاد طبعا هذه الظاهره ليست
توجهها رسميا اقله حتى الان نقول ذلك قبل
ان يرفع بعض المتحمسين نكايه بكوريا
الجنوبيه اعلام كوريا الشماليه وصور
زعيمها كيم جونغ اون
[تصفيق]
اخيرا الماده في القانون مثلا تلفظ
باللهجه اللبنانيه ماده والمراه التي تمد
يدها مثلا ايضا تلفظ باللبناني ماده
النائب سامي الجميل يسال الرئيس مجلس
النواب نبيه بري عن ماده استدد اليها خلال
جلسه انتخاب لمنتخب رئيسا للجمهوريه
فخلط بري بين المادتين في القانون وفي مد
الارجل
عفوا راح استعمل كلامي اللي عم بيستعملوها
بره اذا هذه الجنسيه الجلسات مسخره او ضحك
عدوون او فقط هيك فلكلور معين عم ننزل
مسخره وفي كتاب الوزير بالنيابه يكون
دائما في تلتين دوله الرئيس بيئيه من
النظام
هذا الموضوع منه للمزح
[موسيقى]
ختاما في تجربه علميه وضعت سمكه القرش
كبيره في حوض مائي يضم اسماك صغيره
التهمها القرش على الفور بعد ذلك وضع
الباحثون فاصلا زجاجيا يعزل الاسماك عن
القرش المتوحش الذي هزم الصغيرات دون جدوى
هذه المره مع اصطدامه بالفاصل الزجاجيه
وبعد عشرات المحاولات الفاشله استسلم
للوضع الجديد وتخلى عن غاراته العدوانيه
عندها ازال الباحثون اللوحه الزجاجيه لكن
القرش لم يبادر بالهجوم لكي يحمي راسها
فقد اصبح متيقنا بوجود حاجز يمنعه عن
الاسماء هكذا هي الحمايه تفرض حين بالقوه
وتستمر دهرا بهيبه القوه والامه التي تفقد
هيبتها ستمضي في علوقها اني وكل المتوحشين
الى اللقاء
الخيول العز حين
تتسابقات ترنو
السلام ابطال
كان فيه سمونا
تتوالى
[موسيقى]